يستنجد الديمقراطيون اليوم بالرئيس
الامريكي الاسبق باراك اوباما لانقاذهم من
خساره استحقاق التجديد النصفي بعد ما بينت
استطلاعات رئيس تنام حظوظ الجمهوريين في
تحقيق فوز كبير في الثامن من نوفمبر لذلك
توجب توجه الديمقراطيين الى الرئيس
الامريكي رقم 44 لانقاذ مرشح حيث اكد
متابعون لتطورات الحاصله ان اوباما لا
يزال يتمتع بشعبيه كبيره حتى في اوساط
الناخبين في المناطق التي توصف بانها
متارجحه بين الاحمر والازرق متفوقا حتى
على بايتن حيث حتى اوباما انصاره على عدم
السماح للمخاوف بشان الاقتصاد
والديمقراطيه وقضايا اخرى بدفعهم الى فك
الارتباط مع الحزب في اعتراف بالتحديات
التي يواجهها الديمقراطيون على المستوى
الوطني» وشاله اوباما ثلاث ولايات تعد
ساحات معركه بين الحزين على مدى يومين لح
بتدعم ليه طامحين في مجلس الشيوخ وحكام
الولايات في سباقات صعبه
[موسيقى]